[Music]
you don't know what it's like
losing your hair you might as well be
dead
that could be a serial killer on the
list it's a hairdressing competition
did you kill him
[Music]
how do they even know it's murder
someone scalped him
well you're right
all right
no
he was dead
they follow me dead people all I wanna
do is cut hair
and they keep dropping
how do you tell someone who love has
been
short answers right now they don't care
about perms
[Music]
there's me thinking we're just a bunch
of hairdressers
[Music]
fixing this once more into some kind of
gangster fixing the show murdering the
rivals
I might take that break now
this is the crowns
wow that you never take off
[Music]